the idea was perfectly simple marched to
the presidential palace and tell Omar
al-bashir to resign but this was the
official response rubber bullets tear
gas and live ammunition from an
administration and a man who have ruled
Sudan for 29 years a paralyzing economic
crisis has fueled this popular uprising
four weeks of demonstrations organized
by doctors teachers and other
professionals Bissel are well in AD the
people of Sudan are known for being
particularly determined stubborn and for
playing the long game they are not
hot-headed nor do they despair easily
yet it is a dangerous business in a
suburb of Khartoum called Barry troops
are filmed as they open fire on
protesters the tear gas canister was
fired say activists into a building
where doctors were treating the wounded
residents react with horror at least
three people died in Barry including a
25 year old doctor and a 14 year old boy
staff at the local hospital treated
dozens of casualties but they couldn't
save everyone outside the hospital a
huge crowd gathered shouting in unison
for freedom peace and justice
president al-bashir who's wanted by the
International Criminal Court for war
crimes has presided over an economic
collapse surging prices have fueled
discontent and acts of civil
disobedience once thought unthinkable
have become commonplace Bashir must fall
chanted these worshipers in a cartoon
mosque fall fall fall
an elderly protester was laid to rest
today
one of more than 40 who have lost their
lives since December and the grief felt
here will only intensify the sense of
grievance now Basheer's opponents are
growing in number and determination John
sparks Sky News